hi I'm Megan from Khan Academy and in
this video we're going to explore Khan
Academy's course mastery system at Khan
Academy
we're devoted to mastery learning and
build our content around our course
mastery system however a question we
hear frequently from teachers is what
exactly do we mean by course mastery on
Khan Academy course mastery on Khan
Academy is a feature that allows
teachers to set and track long term
learning goals for students while
encouraging students to work at their
own pace
currently course mastery is available
for courses with full practice content
all of our math courses including AP
Calculus a b b c AP statistics and our
get ready for grade level courses as
well as grammar high school biology ap
biology ap physics 1 US government and
civics
AP US government and politics US history
AP US history world history project
origins AP macroeconomics microeconomics
AP microeconomics and the AP computer
science principles assigning course
mastery goals allows teachers to set and
track long term goals let's walk through
how to assign course mastery goals to
your students when you log in to Khan
Academy you'll land on the teacher
dashboard click on the name of the class
you want to assign a mastery goal on the
left hand side navigation go to the
course mastery placement tab if you
haven't done so already at the on grade
level course you currently teach and if
you're a math teacher add the get ready
for grade level course if you're about
to start the school year we recommend
assigning the get ready for grade level
course as a course mastery goal to have
students begin the year by gap filling
and strengthening fundamentals before
diving into on grade level skills for
example if I have a 5th grade teacher I
would start the year by assigning the
get ready for fifth grade course click
the blue button add these courses now
you'll be on the course mastery
placement page
like a sign goal you can confirm you
assign the desired goals to students by
selecting course mastery placement on
the left hand panel and you will now see
the current mastery goals assigned to
students in your class a student's work
on Khan Academy you can also add
additional courses for students to work
on either below or above grade level you
can assign the same course for all
students to master or you can assign
different courses to individuals or
groups of students we recommend using
Khan Academy's skill report to look more
closely at students progress and
determine the best goal or goals for
each student
now let's look a little closer at what
students see in terms of course mastery
goals when students log into Khan
Academy they will be on their learner
home page each student will be able to
see their teacher or class name on the
left hand side by clicking on the class
students will see their mastery goal a
student can click the goal at any time
and continue from where they left off to
make progress towards their goal
students can continue working toward
their mastery goal on the iOS and
Android apps as well every skill or
concept has multiple mastery levels and
students earn additional points with
each new level there are several ways
for students to practice they can
practice a single concept at a time on
an exercise or they can practice a mix
of different concepts on a quiz unit
test course challenge or mastery
challenge as students get questions
right they move up from not started to
familiar to proficient the top level is
mastered students can only get to
mastered by getting to proficient and
then getting that concept right on a
unit test course challenge or mastery
challenge most teachers recommend having
students start with the courts challenge
or a specific unit test within the
course this way both students and
teachers can quickly identify gaps and
strengths in student knowledge in order
to provide the right content
and rate support in the right moment
when students are stuck or missed
questions their mastery level moves down
and a symbol appears next to the concept
to help them remember where to focus if
students are consistently missing
problems about a concept they'll move to
attempted status and a red dot will
appear next to that concept mastery of
individual concepts contributes to unit
progress and to overall course progress
a mastery goal is considered achieved
once a student reaches 90 percent
mastery though they can still access
previous goals at any time students can
always see what they've completed and
what they should work on next
additionally once students have begun
working in a course they will receive
mastery challenges which appear at the
top of the course page mastery
challenges highlight opportunities for
students to engage in personalized
spaced repetition of the skills students
have already started practicing
research shows that spiraling skills
over time and across lessons is a key
component to minimizing student learning
loss and improving knowledge retention
we'll be diving deeper into reports in a
later lesson
but let's take a quick look at where to
find mastery progress for students
starting at the teacher dashboard select
a class select course mastery progress
from the left-hand panel this report
shows student progress on the selected
course first you'll see class progress
towards overall course mastery and the
median mastery for the class as a whole
below you'll see the mastery for each
unit perhaps at the start of the year
and you're focusing on this first unit
by clicking on any unit you can see the
additional detail of progress for each
student at the unit level including each
student's mastery progress for that unit
and the class median for unit mastery
progress Khan Academy also has a skills
report found under the activity overview
to dive deeper into the individual
skills for a given course
on the skills report you can open any
unit to get a quick view of how students
are progressing for the skills in that
unit by looking at the purple bars on
the right side by clicking on a specific
skill you will be able to see the
mastery level for every student for that
skill if you notice that several
students are struggling on a skill you
can assign extra practice on that skill
right here in the skills report we'll
talk more about how to make assignments
in a separate video some advice from
teacher is using Khan Academy's course
mastery in their classrooms mastering an
entire course can feel daunting to
students so break it up into checkpoints
like monthly goals you can also consider
having students focus on particular
units throughout the year then check the
unit report to see how they're doing
also you don't need to assign the same
course mastery goal to every student to
differentiate you can assign different
courses to different students some
teachers even assign a mastery goal for
a previous grade level as review at the
start of the year we hope this video
helps you get started using course
mastery with your students